- [Mark] All right, Edwina.
Edwina where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in Clayton, Oklahoma
but I was born in Fort
Lauderdale, Florida.
We had moved to Oklahoma when I was
five years old, me and my mom and dad.
That's when they split up for good.
They had been together
for like seven years.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- I can remember way back when I was
three years old in Florida
sitting at the breakfast
table with my mom and dad,
and they had a fifth of,
I mean half a gallon of vodka sitting
in the middle of the
table, I remember this
and Flip Wilson was playing on the TV.
Um, my mom used to take
my beatings for me,
my dad used to, was
very abusive to my mom.
I had got bit by a dog when I was four,
in my shoulder and it was one of them
rottweilers that were
trying to kill the wild
boars out in the everglades.
And she had puppies
and I picked one up and she attacked me.
If the owner didn't come
out, she would have got,
she would have bit my jugular vein
but where she bit my shoulder,
and she tried to go for my neck,
I moved and I got her
scratches on my neck.
But when the ambulance was called
and the police was called,
my mom and dad didn't know,
had no idea I went outside.
I snuck outside because
I wanted to go play
and my dad was gonna beat me
because I wanted to go play,
but my mom took my beating for me.
When the police showed up and
to go get my mom and dad,
they found my mom all beat
up and my dad was drunk
and all this and still beating on her.
When they got there, they took him to jail
and got him for a child endangerment,
spousal abuse, neglect and other things.
My dad spent six months
in jail and got back out.
And that's when we had moved
from Florida to Oklahoma.
I'm the only grand, On my dad's side,
from my dad, I have five other brother,
one brother and four other sisters,
there are six of us,
but with my mom I'm the only child.
I'm the only child my mom had,
so my grandpa on my
mom's side, my mom's dad
I was the only grandchild,
so i was spoiled through him.
That's the only love I have
ever known, genuine love.
- From your grandparents?
- With my grandpa.
- Grandpa?
- My grandpa raised my mom from,
raised my mom and my brother,
her brother, my uncle.
My mother, my grandmother died
giving birth to my mother.
So my mother never knew her mom
and so she never really got
the raised bringing up of,
of a woman thing from a mother, you know
which I never did either
cause my mom never raised me.
I was right like I said,
when I was in first grade
I got molested by my stepdad.
And from then on, it was like
that's how my childhood was,
you know, my only serenity
was going to school and then,
I don't know, It's just like,
I was a lazy child you know,
I really didn't want to
do anything or whatever.
And I got pregnant when I was 13,
with my son Brandon and went
into unwed mothers home,
they took my mother's rights from me.
Me from my mother and
put me in a foster home.
And when I had my son,
I stayed with, I stayed
in that foster home
till I was 18.
- Who was the father?
- His name is,
hold on,
Vanden, his name is Vanden,
He's, he's done passed away already,
he's probably gone.
I haven't been to Oklahoma
since I've been out here.
I've been out here 18 years.
I had my, my oldest
daughter when I was 22.
So there's nine and a
half years difference
between my son and my daughter.
And then, there's like
two years difference
between my other kids, I got five kids.
Me and my ex husband got,
renewed our vows in 1989.
We made we, we, lemme go back,
1997 we renewed our vows.
The church that we renewed our vows in,
the preacher gave the sermon to my
daughter's funeral nine days later.
I was in a house fire,
my house caught on fire,
my apartment and my baby was,
I left my baby up and I got blown.
I know what that feels like for a house
to take a breath cause my house took a
breath and blew me out the window.
I weighed 360 pounds, I was big.
I was a big, big, big, big lady.
And cause no one told
me I wasn't supposed to
gain a hundred pounds when I was pregnant,
at that 13 but
so I had always been big, you know,
don't know, I never did,
never knew nothing, any be
underneath a hundred pounds
or whatever, or 150 pounds or
but I got blown out of
a window probably about,
about this way, it was
an old window pane thing.
And, and the way you raise
the window up like this
and the paint got stuck
and I couldn't get out.
And I busted the window,
which I shouldn't have
because the oxygen hit the
fire and it blew my house,
my apartment. I got blown
30 feet out the window,
out of a piece of glass
this big, 360 pounds.
I had no idea how it
happened, but it's like
somebody just grabbed me
and jerked me through there.
I've had no cuts, no
nothing, but I got blown.
I was burned 27% of my body.
I spent 18 days in the hospital.
We buried my daughter
on the 26th of December.
It would happen December 22nd, 1997.
They pronounced her dead at 3:34 AM.
Fire department was a block from my house,
you could see it, took them
four minutes to get there,
four minutes to put it out.
She was gone by then.
I don't remember much that night.
I couldn't even tell
you where my kids were
but I know that they were safe,
they wasn't burned.
I went through pain.
I know I faced my worst fear.
My fear fire, you know, my
house caught catching on fire,
you know, whatever. It wasn't my fault,
It was my hot water heater
blew up, is what happened.
I had a defective hot water
heater and it blew up.
I had to settle out of
court for 275,000 because
I had a racist judge and
I lived in a racist town.
Indians in Oklahoma are the minorities
because we have casinos.
We have, we don't have pay
taxes and all this and this
and this, like, you know, they
have a, there it's, you know
they looked down on
Indians. Plus It don't help
when our, when the Indian men go out
and get a job and work the
first, till the first paycheck
and then don't go back to work, you know.
My ex-husband he was a
supervisor at a pipeline company.
He, uh, worked at a lucky,
lucky star on his days off.
So I never really worked, I stayed home,
took care of the kids and
went and played bingo.
Drank became a big alcoholic.
I drank a lot, a lot, lot,
but my biggest, my,
my thing, I'm a Pisces.
I have fantasy world and
I live in a fantasy world.
I want a knight in shining armor
and the white horses and all this to come
carry me away and live happily ever after
and that never happens.
I followed my mother's footsteps,
My mother left me when my, my
with my relatives to chase her men
and her drink because she
became an alcoholic real bad.
And I came out here I left
a four bedroom brick home
to come out here to California to sleep on
the sidewalk with somebody
I didn't even know.
I left my marriage and my kids
abandoned my marriage and my kids.
My kids was little.
My baby was in the hospital,
she was four years old.
She was gonna die.
The doctor told me there was nothing they
could do for her cause it was up to her,
it was up to her whether
she wanted to live or die.
She had E coli virus and it
went into her bloodstream
and it started shutting down her organs.
I didn't see my baby again until she
was 19, she turned 20 out here.
I haven't seen my other two kids.
I haven't seen my son since he was four.
He don't acknowledge
me, his mother's gone.
she's dead he don't have no mother,
which I can accept that,
I did that to my children.
I just now recently started talking
back to my kids like about maybe
eight or nine years ago.
I came out here and started smoking crack
and I smoked crack on these streets
day in day out 24/7 for 10 years.
I quit smoking crack about six years ago.
And about six, six years
ago, six-seven years ago.
I couldn't do it anymore,
I couldn't wake up without nothing.
I couldn't even go buy me
a 50 cent soda, you know.
And I justified as, you know, but it's
switching from one drug
to the other, you know,
but crystal meth, I think
crystal meth saved my life.
I switched from crack to crystal.
And, I could do things
like smoke me a bow, go
out handle my business,
do whatever I gotta do and I'm good.
If I smoke crack, all bets are off.
I won't look like this, I'll be
sitting out there on the sidewalk
wondering what happened to me?
How did I get like this again?
Because my head tell me, go get a hit.
It's all it takes, one hit.
I love crack.
It's crazy.
I love it.
I would smoke it today If I could,
I really would smoke like a broke stove.
But I can't because I can't deal with
my consequences, behind my actions.
The things that I would do for it,
I can't deal with that.
I spent seven years, seven months in
twin towers for it, on
two possession charges.
And judge gave me 16 months
with 10 months credit,
I did seven months
And came out with no paper,
no parole, no paper, no nothing.
And that's the best thing I ever did.
When I came out here,
when I first came out here
I weighed 360 pounds. I
went from 360 to 135 pounds
in nine months, smoking crack.
I used to say, if Jenny Craig can't do it
crack can, used to be my motto.
Then I started smoking crystal and
I was a lot better.
I was more, it helped
me more conscientious
about my parents, about a lot of things.
But I think it saved me because
I would have, somebody
was gonna die if I kept
smoking crack and drinking alcohol.
I had to quit drinking too,
I love alcohol.
I had quit drinking too because somebody,
like I said somebody was gonna die.
I was either gonna kill somebody
or somebody was gonna kill me behind it.
Cause I was doing scandalous things.
I come to in a fucking alley on my knees,
sucking dick, excuse my language.
Or having crack.
And I thought, what are you doing?
You know, where's your morals?
These are standards that you would say
you would never cross, look
at you you're crossing them.
I talked to myself like that all the time.
I had to cause I'm the, I'm the
only person that I can talk to.
I can't trust these people out here.
None of them, you know,
they would stab you in
the back in a minute.
Take what you got and
stab you in the back.
But they're your friends,
they got your back.
Yeah right? Okay. And how
many times I heard that.
Your little doorman over here,
he, yeah, he was a negative part
to my upbringing out here.
We don't get along and he don't
like me, I don't like him.
You know, he couldn't get me
to do what he wanted me to do.
And out here and
cause I don't go with these guys out here.
I date I'm whore what can I say, you know,
I sell condoms 20 bucks a pop.
Told judge that one time gave me 60 days.
He picked up these girls and,
and get them to go smoke
or whatever, whatever.
And when the dope was gone he
put them out there on the glade.
And like I said, I don't mess with these
guys out here because I don't feel
that my name should be
coming out of their mouth
or they could sit around a fucking,
sit around in a circle shooting dice
talking about did you know John has
some good head or damn her pussy is good.
You know, they do that to all these
females out here. And I value myself,
you know, a lot more than that
even though I smoked crack or whatever,
I still valued my, you know, myself,
if you ain't got a job,
if you ain't got a house
or you ain't got a car,
you know, I don't go
into alleys, I'm scared
to death of alleys.
I was raped out here once,
I was robbed by gunpoint once.
And I recently sent him into prison for
no less than 22 years for robbing
me and criminal threats cause he wanted
to be a pimp and I
refused to be his whore.
So nobody would help me, so I ended up
calling the police cause he took my bike.
It wasn't my bike, but
he took it regardless.
And I took him to court, I had a witness.
My witness testified with me.
We went to court five times
and he stayed with me.
He went through, he
smokes crack, you know,
I went to treatment with him.
Me and him was in treatment center.
I went to impact, I did impact
out of my two possession charges.
They gave me drug court, Judge Titan, yes.
And I did impact, he gave me 18 months.
It was an 18 month program.
I did 15 months and relapsed
right out here, two blocks down.
Leap year day, drank a beer and my best
thinking said, just go and take a hit.
And I went on eighteen day run and
they caught up with me
and when I went to court,
the judge, I told the judge, I'm not,
I'm not doing this treatment no more.
I'm not, cause I gave him 18 months credit
to go back into treatment.
I didn't know nothing
about the credit system,
cause in Oklahoma you get popped for
anything like this.
You're gonna sit maybe a
month in jail before you go see the judge,
dead time. You don't start don't,
your sins don't start
till you go get sentencing
go to prison or go to jail
or whatever to get sentenced.
Here you've stuff to
go vacation, you know,
so you go in, you out the next day.
The criticism out here is, is remarkable.
First time really went to jail,
they gave me 45 days for prostitution.
I have nine prostitution's under me
but they can only count to seven,
they had to strike two.
Jumped in a car with police every time.
But my best thinking told me to go
and I was mad at my
boyfriend or I was upset or
I wasn't thinking, I
wasn't paying attention
to my surroundings and this and this.
And I'm just going to go get that money.
(mumbles)
There I go, jumped in the car with police.
Wasn't paying no attention that there was
undercover over here and
squad cars over here.
And you know, when I quit smoking crack
and went into crystal, I got real skinny.
I thought that's the shape. I've been,
I have been small since
I've been out here.
My ex husband has never
seen me little like this.
He seen me big, you
know, when he finally see
me little, he told me I was dainty.
Oh, you're so dainty
I'm scared to break you.
My kids have never seen me little.
When my daughter Angela came out here,
She was amazed that I
could put her jeans on.
You can't fit in my jeans, yes I can.
I bet you, I can fit your jeans.
I put her jeans on, she wore size 12.
I could fit a 12, she was amazed by that.
She got pregnant out here.
She stayed out here seven months.
My daughter got me on Zoloft because
everything I said to my mother,
when I was that age, I said to her.
My mother said to me, I said to her.
And it was like watching my, my daughter
through a bubble and I couldn't do
nothing about it because she rubbed it
in my face all the time that I left her.
I abandoned her and her
sisters and left her
and, and I had no right
to tell her anything.
When she told me that she was grown
and she could do whatever
the fuck she wanted to.
I told her, okay, you go be grown.
Just like my mama told me, she packed up
all my stuff put it out on the front porch
pushed me out the door and
told me to go be grown.
That night I got beat up
by my, by my son's dad.
He beat me up, really, really beat me up.
I couldn't open my eyes the next morning.
I couldn't, I couldn't move.
I had bruises on top of bruises.
I had footprint right here.
I was 20 years old when that happened.
And that was the last time I ever took,
I said I was ever going
to let any man hit me.
Because I was not going
to look like my mom.
My mom's got scar tissue all over her
face from being beat up by men.
You know, she always picked the bad ones
that wanted to beat
her, but she loved them.
My mother was Indian Liz, they called her
Indian Liz because she had,
Hundreds of boyfriends or men that she
married or whatever.
She had different name
every weekend getting a nod
every weekend or whatever.
My momma was cool though.
She was really cool.
She died at 52. I'll be 53 in March.
I've been out here since
I was 38 years old.
I grew up out here.
Trust me when I left
Oklahoma, my best thinking
told me that my kids would be better
off with their dad and I could go
sow my wild oats somewhere in California
and that's what I did.
I haven't been back.
But like I said, I've been in contact
with my ex-husband and, and you know.
He still remembers a lot
of things that I forgot,
you know, he brings them
up and we talk about them
and I'm like, Oh yeah right. Oh, okay.
But I never really
realized how much he really
really loved me, you
know, until we started
talking and I really,
really hurt this man.
I hurt him by doing what I did.
I hurt my girls, you know,
so I never was really a mother.
You know, I mean a mom.
She say I'm a mother but I was never a mom
or mommy or, you know, I didn't take the
kids to soccer practice or any of that.
I did once go threaten the teacher
to beat whip her ass, when she let my
daughter get beat up at school.
And she, my daughter got
suspended, I was drunk.
My daughter knew I was drunk she said, no,
mom, don't go just stay here it's okay.
No, it's not. We went
up there and about, yeah
pulled that woman through that door,
but my daughter stopped me.
She was in first grade, imagine that.
I was a very mean drunk when
I drank, very mean drunk.
I used to go to the VOA and sober up,
get out, get out of here for awhile
and go volunteer laundry, be clean for a
while, get all this stuff and then
get a wire hair up my
butt and go take a walk.
And they won't, they wouldn't
see me for two-three weeks.
I'll be out here oh, I'll stick one,
smoking crack trying to get every hit,
you know, every hit I could find.
If I didn't have the money somebody's
gonna give me some
crack, somebody was gonna
come out of their pocket
or sell their ass or
sell their shoes or sell their clothes,
do something, get me some crack.
That's kinda crack head I am,
you know, I'm, I'm that one I've never
stole from my family though.
I've never stolen anything
out here from anybody.
I don't steal, I can't, I don't.
I stole a pack of gum one time,
i got severely beat by my mom.
And so I've never stolen again.
I don't like a liar and
I don't like thieves,
you know, am I saying I never lied?
You know, everybody lies Of course I lied
when it was appropriate, you know,
but to really honestly, to just sit here
and lie to you, I couldn't do that.
You could tell when I'm
lying, I start stuttering
and you know, I look really
guilty when I'm lying.
You get, you just spot it right away.
I've been in relationships out here
Three serious relationships
out of the 18 years I've been out here.
This last one, I'm still
in kinda sorta when
he wants it to be, it's been three years.
We've been together and I left.
I was on my way back to
Oklahoma when he called
me back and told me to come back.
I should've never, I should never turned
around I should have kept on going.
I've slowed down a lot,
I don't come out here
like I used to, I work off my phone.
I got maybe about six
clients that I see now
compared to all the men
that I had out here.
I can't say, I know what I'm doing,
I'm very good at what I do.
I take pride in my job
or my career or whatever
you wanna call it.
My, my condom selling.
And, but like I said,
I'll be 53 years old.
I'm glad I age very, very well.
You know, I'm very glad
that I age very well.
If I would've stayed in Oklahoma,
I think I would be dead by now
because I was so heavy and so big
I think crack really saved my life.
It really did.
You know, made me lose all
that weight and everything.
You can tell me that I wasn't the shape.
My head was this big, I
was this little, you know,
and, and, and I thought I looked good
until they took my
picture, my mugshot picture
and I looked at it and it was like, wow,
walking dead for real.
That's about it.
I smoke weed.
I don't drink anymore.
Oh, my daughter just recently got killed.
My youngest one that came out here.
They found her new year's
eve in the back of a car.
- Just two weeks ago?
- They buried her January sixth.
Motherfucker cut her throat,
cut her throat she was 25 years old.
- What happened?
- He cut her throat.
He, I don't know, I
don't know the details.
My ex husband won't tell me
I don't know the details,
but yeah, he cut her throat and left
her in the back of an abandoned car.
So here lately I've been on a sequent.
I mean, I think I recently sobered
up like about five days ago.
I was, I have been drinking,
I've been crying and,
but she wouldn't want that, you know,
so I think I'm done with that.
You know, I'll let, I let her go and,
and said my little prayer for her and,
and did my little ritual and I'm good.
Just now trying to stay
away from these assholes
and not have to worry
about them bothering me.
I moved out away from here, I had to get
away from here to get away from crack.
So I moved on that side
and I live in a tent.
I've been living there for
three years in this tent.
Never had a tent in my life now
and I get a tent. And I
got three cats and a dog
that I take care of
and a cheating old man.
So, but that's my little
life in a nutshell.
And thank you for interviewing me.
- Thank you very much for coming in.
- You're welcome.
- Great story.